you for that are there more or less of
them than people that are in cults there
are vastly more paying attention than
people in cults yeah well you have to
default yeah I think that's way off
because I think there's like a billion
Catholics
oh if you're gonna call Catholicism it's
a cult I grew up in it okay it's just a
cult with a billion people well you got
a guy who dresses like a wizard and
sitting on a golden throne no boy yeah
that's that's but but that is why this
is a problem is that there's many people
that live their lives by these
ridiculous ideologies that are illogical
okay so I'm gonna challenge you on that
detect them from predators and Facebook
Likes
I'm gonna challenge you on this please
do Catholicism is not a cult what is the
difference you know cult here's I had a
bit for my act we just a cult is
[ __ ] and it's created by one person
and he knows it's [ __ ] in a religion
that guy's dead okay so let me have this
is boy this is rough territory but are
you okay let's say let's say yeah all
right let's say Moses comes down the
mountain with the tablet oh that dude
okay I don't know if Moses did come down
the mountain with the tablet I don't
think he did let's say dead okay um that
he didn't know he was bullshitting
people well do you know what religious
scholars actually believe in Jerusalem
actually believe that was all about now
the whole burning bush tell me they
believe there's the acacia bush which is
rich in DMT and they think the metaphor
of the burning bush was actually a
psychedelic experience and that Moses
during this psychedelic DMT experience
came back from the other dimension that
you go into when you go into the DMT
trance with all this really standard
these standard messages that I've myself
have gotten from these psychedelic
experiences that you have to treat each
other as if we're all one and that our
separations are all illusions that you
are literally living a life that if I
was born in your body and I had your
genetics I would be you and you
would be me because we are all the same
and our differences are really what the
illusion is we were these temporary
beings and that negative thinking and
negative feelings and all these things
manifest themselves in negative actions
and negative thoughts and you can change
that and you can change the frequency in
which you exist in this world okay like
this is essentially what the 3,000 year
old version of Moses or more than that
Moses his tablets were that they were
the God was the burning bush
perfect perfect so can I ask you a
question you've done some hallucinogens
oh yeah and you've had some insight yeah
and that insight had something to do
with treating people yes definitely okay
was it true well it definitely has
benefitted me true or false
I asked me is it true that you have had
positive experiences from psychedelic
drugs where you have interpreted those
experiences and improve your life yes
that's true okay so if you now go and
you convey that thing to somebody who
hasn't had the experience themselves is
it [ __ ] well here's the thing about
psychedelics as opposed to all the other
ideologies is that they're very
repeatable you don't have to believe in
DMT if you smoke it you're gonna
experience it whether you believe in it
or not right and actually I think this
is I mean I am a cautious fan I say
cautious because I don't think I'm not a
fan of the idea that these substances
should be used recreationally I think
that's a mistake
I think I think it's fine to have a
great time but that these things are so
powerful that one should be deliberate
about it and you know don't do it with a
TV the only thing that I like about
doing it recreationally is it's going to
get more people to do it and that if you
think it's recreational and then you do
it there's going to be a certain
percentage of those people that go what
was that that's not what I thought it
was I thought it was going in there to
have a good time and I just communicated
with God yep air quotes god yeah air
quotes well but air quotes God is
marvelous because air quotes God is the
real deal
yeah right in other words it's not a
dude on a cloud right it's something it
is a metaphor for something lodged very
deep in the mind where you can't find it
directly and this is a hack
that many cultures have used to access
that layer and it's all very familiar to
us and when you talk to people that have
studied DMT in particular one of the
reasons why I think it's so familiar to
us when you when you have this
experience one of the first things that
happens is you feel like you've been
there before and they believe that this
is because during REM sleep your brain
produces DMT yeah
you know it's very difficult to monitor
but they have been able to through the
Cottonwood Research Foundation
which all started from the work of dr.
Rick Strassman out of the University of
New Mexico who wrote a book called DMT
the spirit molecule which was one of the
very first times where the DEA allowed
them to do clinical studies on people
with intravenous dimethyltryptamine
which is like [ __ ] serious [ __ ] so
instead of like this 10 to 15 minute
trip you're gone for a long time half
hour plus and deep deep experiences that
a lot of these people mirrored they they
all they they had like super similar
experiences but through the Cottonwood
research foundation they found that live
rats are producing DMT in their pineal
gland this has been proven now which was
really just speculation it was there was
anecdotal evidence but now they know
that rats produced this so they don't
know exactly when people do it because
they would have to do the same thing
they do there rats you'd have to open
your brain up until they develop some
sort of sophisticated detection methods
it's just speculation as to when the
brains producing this incredibly potent
psychedelic drug but it's there
I know it's producing it we know it's
produced in the liver it's produced in
the lungs
it's endogenous to the human system and
we don't know why yeah well I'm pretty
sure I have a good insight into why okay
but for the moment let's pursue the
issue of what the implications are yeah
I'll hold on to wild cross my fingers
yeah cross your fingers on that one the
story you've just told is perfectly
plausible whether it's 100% accurate or
not and we don't know right but the idea
that your mind contains mechanisms that
go into some sort of psychedelic state
without your conscious mind being able
to tap into it so your conscious mind
walks around during the day not
realizing that you're tripping
at some other moments for some purpose
it's all very interesting you're not
tripping in your sleeping mind for no
reason at all you're doing it for
productive reasons logically speaking it
has to be the case that if you're
burning energy and going through the
costly exercise of thinking even in the
psychedelic way that it's happening for
a reason right and that means that we
have carried this with us from an
ancestral state into the modern state
and we now have molecules that we can
trigger it when we want to that gives
you access to a style of thinking that
you're telling me has altered your
understanding of your relationship to
other people and that it metaphorically
lines up with what you often hear
delivered in religious terms right
abstractly yes right and so when you say
Catholicism is a cult
I don't agree because Catholicism
historically must have been delivering
messages that caused people to correct
their thinking in ways that made them
collaborate more effectively that made
them better able to find the
opportunities in their environment I'm
not advocating that we should sign up
for belief systems that are at odds with
our modern environment but one thing we
can say I believe for sure is that
religions that have stood the test of
time did so because their value to the
people who believed in them was so great
that those that disbelieved were out
competed now so we get into trouble in
the modern circumstance because we can
look at many of the teachings of any of
these ancient religions and we can
compare them to what we learn
scientifically and detect that there's
something not right can I stop you there
sure um Scientology is that a cult too
early to tell okay but let's stop well
the guy who created it well we do but we
are huh so let me drag you back a so by
the way I'm very uncomfortable
Scientology and what it does but the
problem is as Scientology itself points
out if you looked at the inception of
something like the Catholic Church you
might be equally troubled sure um which
is why I think they're both cults well
but let's be careful about that okay
what do you think a cult is what do you
think it called it well I think a cult
is the predatory version it is tapping
into people's natural tendency to
believe in what I call metaphorical
truths and it is using it very often to
extract resources from them I see a
church
well no not like a figure the Catholic
Church is so long-standing and the
population that has I guess what I would
say is if a population succeeds by
believing in these things then cult is
not the correct I think you and I have
different terms we're using different
definitions of the word cult on but let
me let me okay take there's a very
interesting comparison so Joseph Smith
who started the Mormon Church had a
competitor right
he had a competitor at the time as a
book called the kingdom of Mathias right
about his competitor at the time and to
me the two looked equally plausible the
story that they were selling now Mattias
never had more than 30 followers and his
religion died out and Joseph and Joseph
Smith won and in the Mormon Church is
obviously a real thing but these sets of
beliefs are advanced by somebody whether
those somebodies are cynical when they
do it or whether they are earnest I
think many of these the ones that we
have that have lasted for long periods
of time have been advanced by somebody
who was in one way or another
conscious or not DMT or not tapped into
something that when delivered to other
people actually constituted a kind of
insight as opposed to being a con man
right okay and so so the origins of the
Catholic Church most likely came from
some desire for order and a scaffolding
of how to behave and to give people rule
and structure for how to get through
this life with the most amount of
positivity in love and by disciplining
them and having these grave punishments
being held over the head burning in the
fires the pits of hell if they decide to
have sex with another man or we're two
different types of cloth or you know
whatever the other silly things that
were in the Old Testament by doing this
what they've essentially tried to do is
offer people structure no it's it's not
really structure it is a an analogue for
truths that can't be spoken literally
because nobody knows how to phrase them
mmm so let's let's deal with the church
on the one hand and Moses on the other
okay
Moses is obviously important in in
Jewish history if Moses ate some DMT
from the acacia bush they think it was
smoke oh he smells why the whole thing
the burning okay does let's say he
smoked it let's say he was super savvy
and farsighted and you know obviously he
didn't know anything about molecules
right I suppose that he had some ancient
model of something and he there must
have been something in that plant that
caused crazy things to happen let's
suppose he didn't believe that he had
contacted God where the God had
contacted him but he woke up from the
thing and was like wait a minute I know
what these people are doing wrong I'm
gonna write it down and tell them came
from God right is Judaism now a cult I
think there are all cults I think all
ideologies are cults I just don't I
don't know I I don't think there is any
one person who wrote first of all when
you're dealing with Christianity you're
dealing with translations right or
Judaism your you're dealing with like
ancient translations of languages that
aren't even spoken anymore right and
you're also dealing with an oral
tradition of who knows how many years
before was ever bothered to be written
down but right but written down by
people and then people decide what stays
in and what doesn't
they changed the rules like the priests
used to be able to marry priests in the
Catholic Church they the Pope
wives sure now that they've ran armies I
mean that this is clearly something that
human beings have a hand in manipulating
and changing and they do it for the
benefit of the structure itself well
they're not doing it for the benefit of
the human beings that are a part of it
they're doing it for the benefit of the
structure itself oh that I don't agree
what's in what case like the money and
the the amount of I'm not I'm not saying
you don't have corruption in all of
these programs you do but I am saying
that there is a it mean this is exactly
parallel to what we were talking about
before there is the predatory version
which I would call a cult right and
there is the earnest version which I
would not call a cult now I'm very
uncomfortable with any of these things
governing policy in the present because
none of them have a literal relationship
with reality that allows them to deal
with the fact that we've got all these
new problems for which there are no
there's no religious wisdom maybe
there's a problem in the word cult maybe
maybe we should just say a structure
created by human beings which is
basically all structures all structures
all models of behavior where you have to
adhere to certain things but the problem
with religion and even with a lot of
cults is these supposed grave
consequences for deviating right well so
all right let's let's pick up
Catholicism because it's easy because so
much of the structure is visible to us
yeah okay I would argue that Catholicism
is gonna be true of all of Christianity
it's gonna be true of Judaism but
Catholicism is it is easy to see how it
would facilitate collaboration that
effectively it would recreate in some
sense the insight that you're talking
about from DMT and that it would
instantiate it in the population in a
useful way that would facilitate
collaboration and disrupt processes that
cause infighting mmm thinking before it
might be a structure it's the
scaffolding for human behavior and
ethics right but imagine I mean we can
see it in Catholicism sure
where it is so every week you have to go
and confess to [ __ ] you're doing wrong
to the dude in the box okay that's how
they used to spy on you I mean that's
what that was for well but why are they
spying on you I mean knows they want to
make sure that they don't get overthrown
well I don't I think I think you're too
cynical really yeah because what do you
think they're doing well so first of all
I'm a biologist okay how are these
priests who don't marry passing on their
genes they're not how they are Oh what
are they doing they're sneaky no their
facility of the lineage that they are in
charge of so the point is they don't
pass on their genes directly they're
passing on their genes indirectly
through the population their interests
are synonymous with the population that
they are they are preaching to and so
you tell the dude in the box that you've
been doing wrong imagine it's adultery
okay oh god I'm if I die before next
week and I haven't confessed my adult
you go to hell I'm gonna go to hell that
dad has a very unpleasant place I'm told
that doesn't get to have something to
tell him so now the person I've been
committing adultery with is thinking oh
[ __ ] well I was gonna keep this a secret
but now the priest is gonna know that
I've been committing adultery he's gonna
hear from the other person and so I
better confess too so now the priest has
a sense of like oh there's an adultery
problem right in the in the congregation
and the priest is you know flipping
through the book and thinking ho this
week what should we talk about and so
you know the priest then gets up at the
pulpit and you know turn your book to
Psalm whatever and starts going on about
adultery and the people in the
congregation who are engaged in adultery
are thinking oh [ __ ] this is God talking
to me directly God knows what I've been
up to and he's not happy and that's why
were reading this Psalm I better cut it
the [ __ ] out hmm right so my point is
the dude in the box
who's taken a vow of poverty he's living
in the church he does well when the town
does well he he's not having babies of
his own so he can't really get ahead by
himself he gets ahead genetically
speaking when the town does well and
he's in a position to
bought what's going wrong in the town
and he doesn't have a dog in that fight
because he's not involved in business
he's not involved in mating and dating
you know it's all relatively recent when
it comes to the Catholic Church in the
last couple hundred yes and I would
argue if you look back at any of these
traditions any of the ones that worked
will successfully have addressed the
question of how you prevent corruption
from emerging well apparently with
sexual corruption these guys were rock
stars like the priests were essentially
the the guys who had the direct line to
God and just like professors have been
known to do not you but you know some
have sex with their students you know
and because they're students like look
at them like oh my god I can't believe
the professor sitting down here with my
work and you mean it's like that's a
very minor connection in comparison to
the connection to God anybody who's
gonna ever anybody who's gonna have
power is in danger of abusing assur I
would say it's interesting that in the
Catholic Church and in other traditions
where marriage and making money are
impossible that these appear to be
evolved what's the word
it's like error correction or protection
from from a virus so an outbreak of
corruption in the church is a bad thing
from the point of view of the well being
of the congregation and something that
says well if you're a priest and you're
spending money in town people are going
to look at you funny because you're not
supposed to have money and if you're you
know hanging around with cute girls
people are gonna look at you funny
because you're not supposed to be having
sex so this limits their ability to to
get away with stuff I'm not saying it's
zero obviously it's not but the idea
that there will be protections in in
each tradition for this that religions
that don't successfully protect against
abuses of power will succumb in
competition to religions that do it
effectively and so you're absolutely
correct that all of the changes in
religious texts that people believe in
that's all human beings making decisions
about right what to keep and what to
throw out and I'm not arguing anything
else what I am arguing is those that
been insightful about what to keep from
the point of view of the particular
problems faced by the population that
they are in will have a competitive
advantage because they will function
more cohesively than a population of
atheists who doesn't have somebody
looking out to prevent outbreaks of
competition inside the delineator
outbreaks of infighting so if you were
looking at it in an objective way like
say if you were an alien from another
planet that didn't understand the
language and you're just observing the
structure you would cease
error-correction the structure would say
oh they realized there's an issue here
with power and so they error corrected
by making these priests be celibate and
then they figured out a way to keep them
from having money and that'll keep them
from being invested in you know Inc okay
yeah I see what you're saying and I
think it's very misleading to people who
analyze things the way you and I would
because there's so much hocus-pocus
associated with these structures that
you know it's like constantly putting a
finger in the in the eye of an
analytical person of course I mean just
the way they dress right I mean just the
wearing the wizard costume and holding
the staff and sitting on the golden
throne and in all of it I mean all the
pageantry to it it's all preposterous
I mean I agree looking at as a modern
person it looks preposterous to me on
the other hand there is no way I'm
telling you I mean most of my colleagues
I'm sure would disagree with this but I
hope to to show them to be wrong on this
front the there is no way that the huge
amount of effort and resource that is
invested in these structures was an
error cannot have been an evolutionary
error because if it was the huge
investment that populations put into
these structures is an opportunity for
some population that behaves in exactly
the same way except it doesn't make that
error to win right but when you get
power and then you have the momentum of
that power overcoming the the population
and then you have positions where the
the the behavior patterns are extremely
restrictive and you have to behave
inside these behavior patterns or
there's grave consequences I mean you
could
conceivably run that for a thousand
years without any error correction and
that's what you've got with Islam right
you've got a very ancient form of
religion that Michael Shermer wrote a
piece about it that's pretty interesting
where he was talking about how it's the
only religion that didn't go through the
Enlightenment mm-hmm and he makes these
comparisons to like the corrections that
have been had with other religions as
time has gone on that haven't happened
there and you could equate it to
resource management you could create it
to the part of the world in which they
live you could equate there's a lot of
different ways you could try to figure
out why this happened but the reality is
that that thing has not changed that
structure has not changed well a long
time I think you've hit on exactly the
the right point
Islam's mechanism for preventing
outbreaks of Chain parasitism was to to
hard-code the thing and this is a
tragedy because it what it means is that
where Islam needs to update it doesn't
have the mechanism for doing it so what
also has a built-in way to keep people
aboard
oh yeah he's become an apostate that
you're allowed you can kill them right
in kill apostates because there's no
other religion that we have right now
that operates like that has draconian
imagines if Scientology did that right
well I mean Scientology obviously has a
huge number of completely unacceptable
mechanisms to keep people from leaving
well but how is that not a cult since it
was created by a science fiction writer
literally out of nowhere I'm gonna be
horrified if I said it wasn't the cult
to tell right so how's that possible
okay so there could be some benefits in
the future if Scientology continues to
evolve and self-correct it could get to
the point where it's a behavior pattern
that could be complementary and perhaps
even beneficial to people I do not
believe that this is where it is headed
but if a thousand years from now it had
flourished and the population that
believed these things
successfully growing you'd have to say
well there's something in that set of
beliefs that's working for these rats so
anyway I I'm not arguing that it isn't
occult it has lots of hallmarks that
make me think I'm troubled by well
including much like Mormonism you know
the guy who made it but this and unlike
Mormonism which was in 1820
we have video we see Elrond hovers bad
teeth and his [ __ ] captain's outfit
on with the medals that he gave himself
you're like hey what is this right oh
right oh you get a planet when you die
or something like that it sounds like a
cult to me on the other hand you know I
mean we've got us the Mormons get a
planet when your dice are used
Scientologists don't get a planet no no
the Mormons do and it was in one of the
Osmond Brothers albums they all went to
these planets like in the album I forget
what the album is it's a hilarious album
but if you open it up it's all planets
and the album the name of the album is
this concept that you get a planet when
you die something that seems didn't read
to me because Lana verse is so big we
can each afford to get as the plan
that's it see that that is some Joseph
Smith [ __ ] by the way it's a wonderful
book if you if you read the the actual
origins of Mormonism people to listen
and go wait a minute what do they
believe wow do they believe some wacky
stuff but he had a golden or a seer
stone rather that allowed him to read
the golden tablets the seer stone was a
special magic rock that allowed him to
read these golden tablets that contained
the lost work of Jesus I was at the
inside of the album with all the planets
so I believe he was actually illiterate
yeah and that was a conman
he murdered put a sheet over his head
and dictated what he was supposedly
reading to somebody else that's my
understanding of it but it was a
charismatic person but many people
who've created cults he was I think what
they did right Mormons are some of the
nicest people I've ever met
they have an amazing sense of community
they're super nice and I've always said
that if I was going to join a cult I
think I joined the Mormons but where
they [ __ ]
as the regulations came in they started
restricting the market they started the
regulator's came in and stopped these
people from having nine wives and then
they're not gonna be so nice anymore the
reason why they were so nice is because
they have these crazy relationships they
were having orgies every night well nine
people live in the house of them they're
allowed to have sex but there's a
problem with your they because for
everybody who had nine wives there were
eight dudes who had not those guys got
to get their [ __ ] together and start
their own cult
I guess we're you know well maybe
they're gay I don't know well what about
the women - right well how about a woman
who has ten husbands you know this is
[ __ ] for her that doesn't happen
yeah it should right now it'd be
possible no now see there's a very good
biological reason it doesn't make any
sense but no polyandrous on me he went